Donald Trump famously pledged to donate
his presidential salary of $400,000 to
charity he wouldn't be taking vacations
during the campaign more on that later
he wouldn't be leaving the White House
much and he would be donating his salary
as you probably know by now the not
leaving the White House and not taking
vacations thing is a broken promise and
I'll dig into the details of that a
little later but let's talk about that
$400,000 salary which Donald Trump
promised to donate Donald Trump refusing
to provide proof that he's donating his
salary as promised Trump's the
presidential salary is paid monthly
meaning that Donald Trump's second pay
day is coming up very soon the White
House has been asked to confirm that
Trump is indeed donating that salary and
they are refusing to make that
confirmation Trump can't just refuse the
salary because federal law mandates that
the president received the $400,000
salary but of course you can donate that
Donald Trump said that he would aides
have said that he would be donating it
but no proof MSNBC requested details and
documentation about the salary donations
that were promised and the White House
the Treasury Department and the Office
of Personnel Management all declined to
say whether or not Donald Trump is
keeping that promise last month White
House spokesperson Sarah Huckabee
Sanders told the web site politifact
that Donald Trump quote will be giving
his salary back to Treasury or donating
under the law Donald Trump would receive
or had received his first paycheck
for just over $33,000 in February he
would be set to receive the next
paycheck for another $33,000 on March
20th and we would certainly be able to
get that information if you've donated
nearly 67 thousand dollars in two months
to charity there would be records of
that we would be able to get those
records and this is not the only
donation promise that was made by Donald
Trump that hasn't been proven remember
that during the transition period Trump
also unveiled a plan to quote donate all
profits from foreign governments
[Music]
from foreign government use of his
hotels and similar businesses to the
Treasury Department that plan was
released by Trump's private law firm
Morgan Lewis no system or accounting
methods have been released no
information has been released about
whether that's happening so let's take a
step back Donald Trump overstated his
charitable donations before being
president and now he is refusing to
provide proof of his charitable giving
during his presidency remember that the
Washington Post during the election
tried to track down confirmation of many
of Donald Trump's supposed donations
that he talked about during the campaign
and many of those organizations
David Farenthold from the Washington
Post called them up they said yeah we
have no record of Trump or the
foundation the Donald Trump foundation
ever having donated to our organization
is anybody shocked the exact same
behavior that Donald Trump was
exhibiting before being president is
being exhibited now that he's president
Donald Trump has also by the way spent
more than 10 times what Obama spent on a
per month basis for traveling back and
forth to mar-a-lago for vacations he
claimed he would never take never mind
the cost of Melania Trump the first lady
staying at Trump Tower in New York City
do any so-called fiscal conservatives
care about this anybody are any fiscal
conservative trumpets or suppose it's
fiscal conservative trumpets willing to
say that this must end or is it all
justified because Donald Trump is Bigley
presidential and doing a tremendous job
absolutely pathetic a lot of discussions
by the way about this on our reddit
discussion forum you can join us there
at david pakman.com slash re d di t
Gamefly is sort of like netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 Wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low use price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30 day trial at
Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s the games
are shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30 day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s